et on va plus loin avec Marie Roger
billoa directrice d'Africa International
Media Group avec nous en direct de
Yaoundé bonjour Marie Roger
et Bruno Darroux chroniqueur
international ici même à France 24
bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël et bonjour
Marie Roger comment aider au mieux
comment aider au mieux l'Ukraine à
passer l'hiver après les derniers
bombardements russes qui ont visé des
infrastructures un quart des foyers font
face à des coupures d'électricité ou des
pénuries d'eau le temps cherche à aider
aujourd'hui et demain à Bucarest les
pays de l'Alliance atlantique confrontés
à une nouvelle arme russe selon les mots
du secrétaire général jamstoltonberg
écouter
le président Poutine essaye d'utiliser
l'hiver comme une arme de guerre
en conséquence les alliés de l'OTAN
apportent un soutien sans précédent à
l'Ukraine et continueront de le faire en
les aidant notamment à reconstruire
leurs infrastructures de gaz et
d'électricité
on va en venir dans un instant à la
stratégie que poursuit l'automne et
Marie Roger sur la question joue de la
situation de l'Ukraine c'est le cynisme
absolu que joue désormais la Russie
rendre l'Ukraine invivable faute de
pouvoir la conquérir la terre brûlée
mais chez les autres
c'est la guerre je s'appelle la guerre
parce que
lorsqu'il y a des conditions climatiques
extrêmes comme l'hiver ça fait partie
des choses qui sont prévues et que les
uns et les autres essaient de l'utiliser
alors avantage soit pour oui comme arme
de guerre comme si tu es circonstances
aggravantes pour infliger des pertes à
l'ennemi donc
dire que
il faut pas avoir l'air de s'en étonner
je crois que c'est tout à fait normal ça
fait depuis le début de la guerre en
évoque cette période de guerre on se dit
tout ça va être plus difficile les
engins et le matériel va s'en lisser etc
donc le fait que la la Russie bombarde
les infrastructures énergétiques et
répréhensible sûrement mais vous savez à
partir du moment où on est dans une
guerre où chacun veut gagner on a vu que
depuis le début la Russie qui a des
difficultés utilisent tous les moyens à
sa disposition oui il semble Bruno avoir
abandonné quand même depuis belle
lurette l'idée de conquérir les cœurs
Vladimir Poutine quand avec les fameux
séparatistes prorus de 2014 a-t-il
encore une stratégie de victoire
aujourd'hui alors deux victoires écoutez
c'est pas évident de répondre à cette
question il a une stratégie avec ce qui
fait de une stratégie alternative en
fait sa stratégie sur le terrain qui
connaît des difficultés du coup il s'est
dit bon on va démoraliser la population
ukrainienne on va peut-être même essayer
de désertifier un peu le pays avec
peut-être des milliers voire des
dizaines de milliers ou des centaines de
milliers d'Ukrainiens qui quitteraient
qui quitterait leur domicile mais une
stratégie de victoire on voit pas très
bien qu'elle peut être le but sauf si
Moscou se dit que oui forcément
l'Ukraine va être complètement
démoralisé mais quelque part ils doivent
bien savoir que depuis le début de cette
guerre les Ukrainiens font plutôt montre
d'une très grande résilience alors même
qu'ils connaissent des difficultés
d'ailleurs des Ukrainiens qui s'étaient
réfugiés en Pologne Roumanie continue à
rentrer chez eux donc stratégie de
Victor certainement pas stratégie
alternative oui et on peut avoir des
doutes sur l'efficacité de cette
stratégie d'autant que les Ukrainiens on
va y revenir continuer à être fortement
aidé par les occidentaux pour essayer de
riposter à cette nouvelle stratégie via
les missiles russes mais oui parce que
face à ce pilonnage à l'Ukraine réclame
encore et toujours des armes écoutées le
ministre ukrainien des Affaires
étrangères
nous avons prouvé que nous pouvions
défaire la Russie et que nous pouvons
gagner ensemble mais les décisions
concernant les armes concernant le
lancement de nouvelles productions
d'armes dans les pays occidentaux
doivent être prises plus rapidement
c'est vraiment une courge de vitesse que
joue l'Ukraine Bruno a fait bien la
Russie avant de succomber finalement à
l'hiver oui alors l'Ukraine sait qu'elle
est engagée dans une course de vitesse
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le ministre
couliba a dit bon jusqu'à présent je
vous disais des armes des armes des
armes là je vous dis plus vite plus vite
plus vite donc l'Ukraine est
parfaitement conscient que
les fabricants notamment acquises
accélèrent la production
mais l'Ukraine continue à dire il nous
faut des armes et très vite notamment il
a résumé ça monsieur couliba il a dit il
nous faut des patriotes et des et des
générateurs d'électricité donc ça j'ai
un tas d'électricité c'est pour
permettre à la machine éner quand il
était fortement impacté de pouvoir
repartir pour que les
Ukrainiens puissent se chauffer puissent
avoir de l'électricité et puis les
patriotes c'est toujours la même
stratégie de la part de l'Ukraine
c'est-à-dire ils disent aux occidentaux
il faut absolument qu'on augmente notre
défense anti-aérienne pour stopper
justement ces missiles russes puisque
tel est la nouvelle stratégie de
l'avenir Poutine faut quand même
rappeler que lors de la dernière frappe
et en attendant la prochaine qui
pourrait avoir la semaine prochaine
lors de la dernière frappe les Russes
quand même on balançait si vous me
passait l'expression 70 missiles sur
l'Ukraine et que les Ukrainiens ont
quand même stoppé 51 donc environ les
deux tiers donc il y a déjà des moyens
de défense anti-aérien mais clairement
la course contre la montre est engagée
les Ukrainiens disent vite vite c'est
maintenant qu'il nous faut un
renforcement de cette défense
anti-aérienne au-delà de la question
morale Marie Roger il en veut aussi de
l'intérêt de l'OTAN d'armée l'Ukraine
comme indique le numéro du magazine
L'Express on va peut-être le voir de
cette semaine les États-Unis grand
gagnant de la guerre un titre
l'hebdomadaire l'Alliance atlantique
affaiblit la Russie à moindre coût
financier et humain pour elle par cette
guerre
et bien je crois que c'est très
intéressant toujours surtout à l'endroit
du public
qui
a tendance à beaucoup à câbler des
Européens de bien montrer que l'OTAN
inclut certes les Américaines bien sûr
mais les uns et les autres n'ont pas eu
le même rôle ni les mêmes attitudes
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine et et et c'est
important de rappeler justement dans ce
contexte que les Européens contrairement
à ce qu'on semble croire en Afrique
ont toujours eu à cœur de ménager la
Russie et on pense à à au sommet de
l'OTAN en 2008 à Bucarest ou
la France à l'époque Sarkozy et
Angers américain déjà c'était opposé à
l'entrée de l'Ukraine c'était pas la
première fois mais il avait à nouveau
bien exprimé
contre la vie de Monsieur double
qui avait demandé qu'on promette à sans
une date mais il promettent de de la
faire entrer à l'OTAN et ça ça fait
partie des choses qui ont beaucoup
irrité la Russie et là il y a une
interview très intéressante de Angela
Merka récemment dans le spiege qui
repartent cette période et qui est parce
que maintenant on a tendance à
l'accablir en disant ben c'est
un criminel la politique d'ouverture
d'engagement actif vis-à-vis de la
Russie qu'elle a eu et où elle explique
bien que
elle a toujours que c'était prendre au
sérieux la parole de la Russie était
juste un signe d'intelligence politique
et que donc c'est pas la même attitude
maintenant en revanche maintenant que le
la Russie a quand même outre passer les
toutes les lignes rouges avec cette
agression Ukraine je crois qu'on peut
pas douter une seule seconde que l'OTAN
le camp occidental va soutenir
l'Ukraine jusqu'au bout parce qu'il
engrais il est en bas de sa propre
crédibilité de la force survie on ne
peut pas comme certains semblent le
croire
s'attendre à ce que les États-Unis
disent bon on a déjà assez financé on va
s'arrêter on a assez armé on va
s'arrêter parce que
George Bush pardon parce que
on s'attendait à ce qu'ils soient
affaiblis par les médecins mais ça va
être une politique active d'engagement
donc
ils savent que on ne peut pas s'arrêter
en si bonne route les Russes également
donc c'est pour ça que tout ça va être
très très difficile et que on peut
encore assister à une certaine escalade
on ne peut pas s'arrêter et on n'a pas
intérêt même à s'arrêter entre entre
guillemets en si bon chemin j'ai envie
de dire même si des milliers de
l'ukrainiens le souffre et pour certains
pays de leur vie aujourd'hui face à une
Russie qui s'affaiblit à vue d'oeil
Bruno et est-ce qu'on contrepartie va
pas falloir quand même à un moment une
autre arrêté une date donnée une date
d'adhésion à l'Ukraine pour pour l'OTAN
ou c'est pas du tout le moment alors je
pense que franchement c'est pas l'ordre
du jour de donner une date à l'Ukraine
pour une adhésion à l'OTAN parce que il
y a quand même plusieurs étapes à
franchir avant il faut arriver à la fin
de la guerre il faut négocier comme en
négocier entre eux et ukrainiens et à
mon avis après peut-être selon la
manière dont on tourne les choses on
pourrait donner cette perspective
à l'Ukraine il faut bien voir oui que ça
va pas s'arrêter parce que quand même
pour les États-Unis effectivement la Une
de L'Express est tout à fait parlante ce
sont les grands gagnants de la guerre
parce que ils sont quand même là en
train d'affaiblir
un leur principaux concurrents la Russie
de par la faute de la Russie qui s'est
mise un peu toute seule dans cette
situation en pensant que que tout se
passerait bien ça leur coûte certes un
peu cher mais enfin c'est une guerre qui
mène par proxy comme on dit puisque ce
sont les Ukrainiens qui se battent et ce
sont les Américains qui fournissent
l'armement alors cert il y a des
problèmes de d'approvisionnement etc
mais Joe Biden a répété aujourd'hui que
une des priorités de ce gouvernement
c'était de continuer à financer l'effort
de guerre
ukrainien donc ils vont ils vont
continuer donc un ils sont en train
d'affaiblir considérablement la Russie
les États-Unis sans avoir les mêmes
conséquences négatives que les européens
notamment en matière de livraison
d'énergie et de justement ce dans le
domaine énergétique ils sont en train de
littéralement de de rafler la mise avec
d'autres pays mais eux franchement sont
en train de rafler la mise parce que la
production par exemple de gaz naturel
liquéfier aux États-Unis à littéralement
explosé au cours des deux derniers
trimestres certains experts estiment
qu'elle a été multipliée par 3 et un une
des destinations de ce de ce gaz naturel
liquéfié bah ça va être notamment
l'Europe et tout ça est produit à bas
coût aux États-Unis et les Européens
payent plus cher c'est d'ailleurs un des
objets de la visite un peu compliqué
quant à Emmanuel Macron aux États-Unis
je referme la par leur ensemble dès
demain cher Bruno la République
démocratique du Congo elle retient son
souffle l'accord de cesser le feu semble
tenir du moins en partie dont le Nord
qui vous pas d'affrontement depuis
vendredi entre l'armée congolaise et les
rebelles Tutsi du M23 juste des
accrochages signalés entre ces derniers
et des ministres où tout mais pas de
retrait non plus des zones occupées par
la rébellion c'est le statu quo Marie
Roger
justement tout est là tout est dans ce
stade la
rébellion la du M23
à accepter n'a pas accepté ceci on dit
oui on ne peut pas partir de cet accord
nous on avait déjà décidé
c'était le
feuilatérale selon nos conditions et
donc si cette situation semble tenir en
ce moment c'est parce qu'ils occupe déjà
les trois quarts du territoire qui sont
disputés parce que c'est des soeurs
qu'il s'agit je crois que au-delà du
conflit actuel et ponctuel il faut quand
même regarder qu'est-ce qui est en jeu
quoi il y a une tentative de redécouper
de redessiner les frontières de la RDC
et on s'est rendu compte déjà au plus
tard depuis
1997 à la chute de Mobutu que une
étendue géographique vaste n'était pas
synonyme de puissance militaire parce
que ça fait au moins depuis cette
période que le Rwanda menace envahi
un filtre la RDC et que tout ça ça a été
extrêmement bien documenté notamment par
l'ONU dans de multiples rapports la RDC
est un pays supplicieux on parle de
millions de morts depuis la fin des
années 90 et il faut se demander aussi à
quoi on servit c'est missions de de
maintien de la paix plus que etc
au Mali et donc maintenant
quand on regarde la position du Rwanda
qui est soutenue par des grandes
puissances et des grands groupes
internationaux tout ça et premier
rapport on se demande si les Congolais
sont conscients de ce qui est en train
de se passer et que cette proposition
déjà de zone tampon qui veulent créer
est-ce que c'est pas déjà le prélude a
une voilà une partition voilà absolument
terrain que les
impunité totale depuis qu'elle a
commencé il a commencé tout ça et on ne
voit pas toutes les Congolais une
réponse qui soit à la hauteur Bruno
justement ce qu'on observe là est-ce le
résultat finalement du poids pris
aujourd'hui par Paul Kagame au plan
régional et dans son dialogue même
effectivement avec de possible
médiateurs dans sa capacité finalement à
et bien ne pas faire évoluer la
situation dans dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo il
n'était même pas présent d'ailleurs
c'est pour parler en fin de semaine
dernière c'est ce qui explique peut-être
que le M23 ne s'est pas retiré
aujourd'hui oui alors il n'était pas
présent parce que le gouvernement
rwandais lui il dément les accusations
de Kinshasa qui disent qu'il est
impliqué dans un soutien actif
om23 c'est ça qui explique que ni le M23
ni le Rwanda n'était présent après comme
il s'est marié Roger ça a été quand même
assez documenté il y a de toute façon
sans entrer dans les détails un soutien
du Rwanda au M23 qui est donc Tutsi
évidemment ce qui ce qui ce qui joue ce
qui permet aussi à Rwanda au Rwanda de
se projeter un peu régionalement dans
cette zone qui par ailleurs on n'a pas
le temps d'entrer dans les détails non
plus mais très riches en ressources
notamment ressources minières c'est
quand même une des causes de la
situation qu'on connaît dans cette zone
de la RDC depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans et du coup effectivement Kinshasa
ben ils essayent de réagir alors devant
l'impuissance notamment de la Monusco la
mission de l'ONU qui n'arrive pas à
mettre en oeuvre une paix et alors même
que le M23 qui s'était un peu apaisé a
repris toutes ces opérations printemps
et se retrouve un peu comme en 2012 ah
je crois une vingtaine de kilomètres de
Goma là ce que veut éviter Kinshasa
c'est la chute de la capitale
provinciale donc Kinshasa fait appel au
Kenya à l'Ouganda qui joue aussi un rôle
très ambigu dans cette affaire pour
monter une force une force armée une
force militaire d'Afrique de l'Est bon
il faut la mettre en place il faut la
financer et pour le moment je crois
qu'il y a que 200 soldats Kenyans qui
sont arrivés sur place on verra si cette
force africaine qui prend un peu le
relais de de l'ONU en pour essayer
d'imposer une paix aura une quelconque
efficacité merci Bruno daroumer merci à
Marie Roger Billaud qui était avec nous
en direct de Yaoundé c'est la fin on va
plus loin merci de nous avoir suivi